invité de 5 à 10 ce matin je vous êtes
malin député de la première
circonscription de la martinique celle
du centre et membre de bâtir le pays
martinique bonjour je vous êtes manage
bonjour monsieur livory alors vous êtes
manège que vous pensez comme louis
boutrin que le tcsp sûr en fonction
avant le 15 janvier
alors écoutez monsieur livory avant de
réagir donc à cette question prégnante
en martinique je voudrais d'abord ça lui
toute la population martiniquaise fermi
veut de d'espérance mes voeux de santé
et d'amour pour notre territoire il pour
une population qui en a bien besoin
alors provenir donc à la question que
vous me posez
écoutez je veux garder l'espoir que ce
test que ce tcsp puis soul et le 15
janvier c'est monsieur boutrin l'a dit
je crois que monsieur vous traitez
étonné lui il doit être un élu de parole
je pense que l'ensemble des élus de la
ctm aujourd'hui qui conduisent le pays
sont les élus de parole et que le 15
janvier sinon le 31 janvier nous verrons
où les le tcsp que nous attendons tous
depuis les années on voit que les
discussions avec les taxis co vous avez
déjà mené vous des discussions avec
ledit taxicos vous étiez présidente la
dernière présidente d'ailleurs du
conseil général c'est aussi facile que
ça de mener des discussions avec le taxi
qu on n'a pas cette impression là le
temps si c'était aussi facile je crois
qu'on serait déjà adjugé donc à une
solution pérenne à une décision qui
serait prise depuis bien longtemps
je veux pas m'avancer et peut-être
qu'effectivement les discussions ont eu
lieu en turquie avait teen movies
négociatrice à l'époque n'aurait coûté
non pas du tout puisque je rappelle que
nous avions négocié pendant presqu'une
année avec les deux syndicats de des
taxis collectifs
ça n'a pas été facile vous savez très
bien que ce que c'est quand même une
profession qui a rencontré pendant de
très longues années de grosses
difficultés en matière de transport
puisque je rappelle que ce sont des gens
qui faisait le transport donc
sur leur propre compte et y ça n'a pas
été simple pour effectivement de
s'adapter à une nouvelle démarche de
transport en commun
cependant pendant très longtemps pendant
près d'une année comme je le disais nous
avons le discuter échanger avec quelques
fois le ton a monté avec nous avec
l'autre parce que ce sont quand même dû
responsables syndicaux très à cheval sur
un certain nombre de choses et je
voudrais quand même rappeler que nous
avons avant mon départ du conseil
général votée en commission permanente
une décision qui réglait peut-être pas
totalement cette problématique avec donc
les transporteurs nous avions donc pris
la décision au niveau de la commission
permanente du conseil général
d'attributs donc une certaine somme aux
toxicos ceux qui étaient sur la base du
volontariat ça dit ce qu'ils voulaient
partir mais aussi ceux qui étaient
malades qui avait un certain âge je
rappelle quand même qu'il y à des
transporteurs qui ont plus de 75 ans et
que ce n'est pas normal aujourd'hui que
ses paires de femmes dont soit derrière
un volant de taxi donc sur ce dossier la
huitaine si on verra bien s'ils disent
avant le 15 janvier ou voir même au plus
tard le 31 janvier mais qui s p sera en
service mais j'ai envie de vous dire que
nous sommes quand même en confiance
vis-à-vis de nos élus
si une promesse effectivement que ce
tcsp roule mais 86 comme vous le dites
si on devait faire un bilan de votre
votre action parlementaire depuis votre
élection en juin dernier ce serait
plutôt une strie puceau son bilan plutôt
mitigé parce que dira aussi regarder un
peu
votre action parlementaire quatre
amendements alors on va reprendre que je
cite que cette partie là quatre
amendements et quatre amendements il
recevable 82 m'ont posé quatre membres
recevable c'est le dur apprentissage de
la vie de député
comme vous le dites l'apprentissage est
difficile mais il n'ya pas effectivement
que l'apprentissage en matière de
propositions de loi ou d'amendements
il y a d'abord une installation un peu
longue parce que bon comme vous le dites
moi j'étais je suis nouvelle députée
élue donc le 17 juin il fallait donc un
temps d'adaptation je suis arrivé à
l'assemblée le aux environs du du vin du
26 juin donc le temps de me refaire donc
à cette vie de m'installer de prendre
possession de certains nombres de
j'ai envie de dire deux choses
administrative de rechercher donc des
collaborateurs parce que voulant comme
si tu étais nouveau il fallait chercher
un collaborateur parce que on ne fait
pas une campagne électorale en ayant
déjà sous les bras donc les
collaborateurs ne savez pas si vous
serez lui donc il a fallu effectivement
faire ce dimanche là il a fallu
effectivement mettre en place toute la
lame la partie recherche de permanence
etc etc
dans tout ça c'est un ami du temps et
puis comme vous dites le temps de
l'adaptation
donc c'est vrai que je suis aujourd'hui
installé à part entière à un groupe à un
groupe de gauche et le travail se fait
et je ne suis pas là pour comptabiliser
tout ce que je fais à l'assemblée
nationale corps pourquoi vous êtes
rattaché financièrement en tant que
député ou au ppm mais écoutez c'est une
démarche et une démarche tout à fait
logique
moi je suis membre de parti politique je
suis membre de bâtir le pays martinique
pour rendre à bâtir juste omis alors il
se trouve effectivement que lors de
notre déclaration de candidature elodie
dimanche administrative que nous avions
certainement loupé une dimanche au
niveau de la préfecture
ce qui fait que nous avons reçues
traitant comme l'ensemble des
parlementaires
la demande de rattachement à un parti
politique
lorsque nous avait effectivement fait
les vérifications
la préfecture a simplement déclaré qu'il
manquait un document dans le dossier a
été déposé
ce qui fait que au lieu justement de
perdre s'ils font là nous avons préféré
justement demandé à au ppm comme
beaucoup de parties de trois partis
politiques
ce n'est pas une problématique de deux
fautes de mon parti politique pas du
tout hein c'est simplement un document
qui manquait donc à cette déclaration
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
avons demandé au ppm effectivement de
loger le nous nos subventions de parti
politique d'accords parmi vous chevaux
de bataille il y à la santé et
particulièrement la situation des
hôpitaux en martinique vous avez
d'ailleurs alerté le gouvernement
aujourd'hui le chum est placée sous
administration provisoire
la situation est critique le rapport de
la cour des comptes est accablant il y a
trop d'emplois notamment trop d'emplois
administratifs que fait-on dans ce cas
la question difficile
vous savez nous n'avons pas été dans une
démarche dit nous simplement parce que
ce dossier de l'hôpital haïti pris à
bras le corps par l'ensemble des
parlementaires je veux rappeler que
lorsque nous avons j'ai fait
effectivement cette question
gouvernement sur le problème de la santé
en martinique c'est le problème donc du
chum
nous avons tous été
deux communes accord nous avons pris la
décision effectivement de nous charger
de ce dossier auprès du ministère des
affaires sociales et de la santé
là le gouvernement parle bien du
rééquilibrage financier avant tout
investissement
oui c'est ça vu que ça veut dire ce que
ça veut dire oui aussi c'est clair y
écouter de toute façon il y a un rapport
donc de la chambre régionale des comptes
qui valide effectivement la
problématique financière de l'hôpital et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je dis que
ce n'est pas donc une
une commission
une administration provisoire qui va
régler le problème donc des finances de
du chum sur soi même si moi pour vous et
azur iso six mois pour faire un état des
lieux ils ont six mois pour faire de sa
vocation dire ça veut dire qu'il ya de
la casse
ils ont six mois a fait des propositions
au gouvernement au ministère de la santé
mais pendant six mois on ne peut pas
combler le trou des années effectivement
de l'égrappage finances habitude d'avoir
des suppressions de lits et puis des
suppressions de postes égalment écouter
ce que je veux dire c'est que nous je ne
suis pas dans une démarche de
suppression ni de lit ni de personnel
vous savez très bien que quelle que soit
l'entreprise qui a des difficultés
leleu on n'est pas dans une démarche de
suppression de personnel
maintenant il s'agit effectivement de
rééquilibrer de ne pas faire du
recrutement à tout va plutôt du
recrutement du personnel médical que
nous recrutement du personnel
administratif c'est là où le bât blesse
mais vous savez très bien qu'aujourd'hui
les pères et des mères de famille
martiniquais ne seront pas dans je pense
dans une démarche de se faire remercier
par l'hôpital
donc ce n'est pas du tout la solution
que nous avions envisagé avec avec la
ministre
nous avions bien précisé que si nous
étions d'accord pour une administration
provisoire
nous n'étions pas du tout mais pas du
tout d'accord dans des problèmes
problématique de personnel qui serait
effectivement remercie donc là je suis
claire
je ne veux pas que le maintien on dise
que je vous êtes mané a donné son accord
bout qui est du personnel qu'ils soient
mis au chômage
non pas du tout autant je me suis battue
sur la problématique de contrats aidés
ou alors que nous avions des pères et
mères de famille qu'ils étaient
remerciés
là encore je ne serai pas dans la
démarche effectivement de d'être
de cautionner donc que le renvoi du
personnel autre aspect de la santé ce la
décision de l'europe de renforcer par un
vote
et pardon la décision de l'europe
d'augmenter les doses légales de
chlordécone dans la viande et dans la
volaille décision donc soutenu par le
ministre de l'agriculture et par lé n 16
l'agencé de sécurité sanitaire est ce qu
on empoisonne les antillais alors la
question est posée c'est à lui que je
veux rapplique lors de la campagne
électorale l'ensemble des candidats
avaient donc dans dans son dossier de
campagne la problématique de la
chlordécone cette décision est arrivé il
y a quelques semaines et nous sommes
dans une démarche du thé au pit
d'interpellations dans ce qu'il fait
mine jusque là que c'est violer parce
que ce ne fut pas une mobilisation
générale
mécontente de cause de cause nationale
de plusieurs choses ans dans l'hexagone
nationale
il faut d'abord été appelés il faut
d'abord interpellé avant de se mettre
justement autour d'une table pour
pouvoir travailler sur le sujet on ne
peut pas déjà
c'est la problématique que nous avons
nous ne devons pas justement aller trop
vite dans un dossier et échoue
effectivement dans la d'image que nous
entreprenons clients génocide par
substitution mais j'ai envie j'ai bien
envie de le dire j'ai bien envie de le
dire je vous rassure ce dossier de la
cour d'école sera une fois de plus
prison mais par les parlementaires
absolument pas un parlementaire parce
que je veux rappeler qu'aujourd'hui nous
travaillons tous ensemble sur les gros
chantiers martiniquais sous les gros
dossiers qui concernent la martinique et
la chlordécone sera donc un prochain
chantier sur lequel nous allons travail
à oka déterminé josette manin je vous
remercie et excellente journée sur notre
antenne c'est moi qui vous remercie et
je souhaite donc une excellente journée
à tous les martiniquais qui nous ont
écouté ce matin
merci beaucoup